[Applause]
thank you very much i know
i know why you're happy tonight because
your
[ __ ] liberal arts degrees are
getting paid off isn't that great
yes
president biden made it official he's
going to pay off for giving over 300
billion dollars
in college debt and uh today he was
voted the sexiest man alive on
triggerdaddys.com
now the the kids were they were giving
up on him now they love him
i was i was on melrose boulevard today
oh my god everybody's wearing aviator
glasses and
they're all getting no malarkey tattoos
it's amazing
kids
oh the kids
they always say they want fresh and new
and they go back to vintage
speaking of that boy did you see what
happened in this city of casseville
missouri they're going back to spanking
in
there you can applaud that you don't
have to be afraid of that
but it's it's not working uh not with
gen z uh today the principal was
spanking some girl and she said that was
hot but i'm more into choking
[Applause]
oh
and just just in time for back to school
they did fire the chief of the police
there at the school in uvalde texas
three months later
he
he went in for his performance review
and they said wait in the hall he said
way ahead of you
you